the prime minister and president of mali
have been arrested by the army in an
apparent coup
in recent months demonstrations have
taken place in the capital bamako
calling on the president to resign
but let's find out more our defense and
security correspondent alastair bunkel
joins us now
must protest years of violence then uh
what's going on
well it started as a mutiny at a
military base outside the capital bamako
earlier on this afternoons we're looking
at very closely
then the government released a pretty
unusual conciliatory statement i mean
they were clearly pretty worried about
what
uh had been happening and then tonight
the
president president kita and the prime
minister have both been
seized and detained by these military
uprisings so it would look as though it
is
a coup d'etat it is not yet a successful
coup d'etat
if that is what it is the reasons behind
it are still unclear some reports that
it was over
a pay dispute early on but as you say
there's been protests in the country now
for
months over corruption over a weak
economy
and significantly over the growing
spread of jihadism
across mali now mali sits sort of in the
center
of the sahel region one of the most
unstable most violent regions
in the world in west africa it is
been overrun by islamic state by
al-qaeda and by other islamist groups
back in 2012 the french military were
forced to intervene it's of course a
no french colonial uh country they were
forced to intervene after another coup
there were around about 5 000 french
troops still in the country based
largely up in the north around the town
of gao there are british military there
as well
helping that that french mission there's
a large u.n peacekeeping operation
that's been pretty
ineffective so far and so this will have
western
capitals spooked if they are going to
get on top of
uh islamic extremism in the sahel then
mali is crucial to that they need the
government support they need to
dampen down the security situation in
mali otherwise it really could have
an impact that affects everybody in the
western world